bon on a une défection vers minutes
défection oui défection donc j'ai des
consignes précises mais sur l' enquête
vais venir
il était comme un fou il est venu boire
au bureau y est et puis là je ne sais
pas apparemment et bienfaitrice jean
lloret metella des gens lui aurait monté
la tête non on parle je vous dis d'un
complot non mais je ne rigole pas je
vous jure qu on est sur un complot dont
convenait en train de mener l enquête
on va vous donner des infos tout au long
de l'émission lionel stan le directeur
général est actuellement sur l' enquête
et louis doc gynéco que fait-il qui le
manipule on saura tout sur cette
personne qui est une personne qu'on aime
et qui apparemment voilà je vous le dis
aux rêveries y est à cause d'une autre
personne que je peux pas vous dire j'ai
des petites infos caméra je vous les
donnerais pendant l'émission mais c'est
bien c'est plus embêtant que ce qu'on
pensait je connais initiale du mec qui
manipulent cette fabrique chimie tu me
djiby dit petit bidon c'est une vanne de
kuji blessés marque de whisky c'est plus
drôle quand on les comprend les blagues
c'est surtout plus drôle quand c'est
d'autre ne gens qui les font sentir
c'est pas la peine puisque je dis les
choses à dire qu'on sable vous avez
goran ou non si on peut aussi donner
notre ressenti parce qu'au début on
rigolait mais moi je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on peut moins rigoler
parce que j'ai pas trop apprécié je peux
dire en fait on est juste peiné parce
qu'on les aime trop et ça se passait
super bien avec lui il n'y a pas de
délire et doc gynéco il écrit un truc le
matin à 16 heures on n'a pas assez leur
domaine femmes font même pas réagir à ce
qu'ils vivent ensemble dans des versions
non mais doc gynéco on ne fait pas ces
tables et on fait pas du tout cas de ce
qu'il écrit ou de ski di c notre pote
donc voila moi j'ai pas envie de huawei
donc on verra
apparemment avec quelques appuis montre
la tête à essayer de tomber à temps mais
je le dis il faut très bien rentrer
demain c'est ton petit voilà ça donne
alors je vais vous dire la vérité
il nous a demandé il a demandé à l'onu
ce stade le directeur général d'appeler
son agent lyonnaise tonnes et est tombé
sur un rabbin très sympa non c'est vrai
que moi je suis juste son rabat joie
énorme et c'est encourageant
la voilà je vous le dis voilà sur l'eau
qu'est ce qu'il écrit à 12h n'est pas ce
qui va écrire à 14 ans mieux versa